meet scientist Chung who's arriving in
his laboratory in Umi o Sweden as
Frank's go this one really blew me away
yes this pneumatic prank was a massive
hit on the internet scoring 2 million
views
but what propels tom across the room you
have here a high-pressure pneumatic
cannon how does this work you have a
cylinder and into the cylinder you push
and push a lot of fun now you pull the
trigger and you release this very
compressed gas part of the cylinder and
what happens is that it tries to
equilibrate with the atmosphere on the
outside and it expands so fast that you
create a pressure wave and this pressure
wave has an enormous force but it's
going to have the greatest effects on
areas of our body that are filled with
gas as the pressure wave hits the gas in
these spaces our eardrums our stomach
our lungs gets really compressed and
then once the wave passes the gas
expands again and if it does this
quickly enough with enough force we
could do some serious damage some
tearing of membranes exploding of our
eardrums and then potential for damage
here is quite high so if he had actually
been hit by a cannon that caused him to
fly back into the lockers like he did he
would have been bruised possibly deaf
possibly had internal organ damage and
may even have life-threatening injuries
if this was for real Tom wouldn't stand
up and smile he would be seriously
injured
yes this one is just clever editing back
to work gents